all right
let's let's camille is going to tell me
if we're live or not
we're live great well welcome to all of
you
here uh in the yale school of medicine
uh
kindly uh loaned this uh
uh uh auditorium to the yale school of
public health for
our event uh with governor
ned lamont and mayor justin ellicker
i it's my pleasure as dean of the school
of public health my name is sten
vermonde to
introduce the president of our
university peter salabe is the 23rd
president
in yale's history and although his
primary appointment is in psychology
we're very proud to call him yale school
of public health
uh faculty member because he has a
secondary appointment for many many
years
in our school as well not only that but
the first lady of yale
uh marta moret is a graduate of our
school so we feel we have an
in in the president's office although
that's just sort of a feeling not a
reality
uh because the president serves the
entire university
so on that note peter we are going to
turn it over to you
for your greeting and introduction of
our panelists today
well thank you dad it's
great to see our panelists and uh
i know many of you are watching on the
zoo for youtube and uh
martial who you just mentioned that is
one of them uh
she and i are very proud of our
associations with the uh the elizabeth
to all the school of public health
students welcome
to a new and certainly extraordinary
academic year i'm just so grateful that
we can
pursue with you our mission of education
and research
practice uh we're doing that partly in
person and
and mostly remotely but uh i'm glad we
are
all now and this semester and the reason
why we can be
so aggressive in pursuing uh
education and research in this
challenging time
is because of the strong leadership of
governor ned vallant
and mayor justin oliver
the support and open communication
between their teams and experts working
at yale
indonesian across the state has been
phenomenal and i am just so
so grateful to the two of them and to
everyone
else who has been making it possible to
keep
our campus our city and
our region and our state safe
all of that good work includes exemplary
uh an exemplary report and wonderful
ongoing work
uh from the reopened connecticut
advisory group
the network has benefited from
contributions by
members of the elk community some of
whom are with us
uh today we've been able together to
significantly
reduce communal transmission of coven 19
since the peak in april and as we work
and as we study together this semester
we know that we share a responsibility
to maintain and encourage
what is a positive health uh positive
public health situation
relatively speaking in our state
so today you will be hearing from the
leaders
who have contributed immeasurably to the
health improvements in our region
and in our state and it is my honor to
introduce them to you
governor ned lamont has served
communities in connecticut
as a business founder and as a volunteer
teacher
and through multiple roles in public
service
he became the 89th governor of the state
of connecticut
in 2019 mayor justin ellicker grew up in
this state and earned his mba
from the l school of management and a
masters in environmental management
from the yale school of the environment
after years of working in public service
he was sworn in
as the 51st mayor of new haven at the
beginning
of this year albert koh
is a co-chair of the reopened
connecticut advisory group
and he is the chair of the department of
epidemiology
of microbial diseases and a professor of
epidemiology
and of medicine engineering
is co-chair of the reopen connecticut
advisory group
uh board co-chair of advance connecticut
and former ceo of pepsico
she earned her master's degree from the
yale school of management and has served
as
a yale trustee maritza bond is the
director
of health for the city of new haven
she served and led in the public health
sector for over 18
years thank you all for being with us
today
and it is my pleasure to now turn things
over to mayor eloker
uh to speak thank you all for being here
and thank you panelists especially
thank you uh peter for those kind
opening remarks
um and i i obviously thank you to so
many of the people on stage for the work
that you've been doing to help support
uh all of our residents around the state
and in new haven
to keep us healthy we've been doing
pretty well we've been doing pretty well
and that's
in large part because we've been clear
on following the science following the
research
and our residents around
the state have overwhelmingly been
cooperating in mass wearing social
distancing
and following the so many guidelines
and when you think about the importance
of
the many students that um are part of
the yale school of public health
and uh the many new students and the
journey you're going to be embarking on
uh now is a time more than ever
when uh your goals your passions your
mission
is underscore the importance of it is
underscored and the kind of impact that
you can have
on the health and well-being of everyone
i'm sure that has not been lost on you
as
you have experienced in so many ways i'm
sure around the u.s
and around the world with this pandemic
but um i want to encourage you and i
presume that many of you
particularly those students that are in
the yale school of public health
are interested in the public service
component of this
but the public service component of your
your education while you are here
and beyond that is vital to uh
keeping people alive and especially in
these times
when we look at the inequities that have
been
so rawly exposed by coven 19
and that have been highlighted even more
by the protests around the nation
i urge you to think deeply about
your role in addressing those inequities
it's there's exciting possibilities but
it's also
critical that we push ourselves to think
out of the box to be open to criticism
and to think deeply about how our
personal
roles and the organizations we represent
can play
a sig have a significant impact on
addressing
so many inequalities that exist i'm
grateful to have the opportunity to be
here
and stan am i supposed to turn it over
to the governor now
that's right governor lamont
good morning and um peter i like that
halo like rainbow in your background
that's a divine it gives us a little bit
of hope
and uh justin thank you as um justin
said um
we're following the science but it's not
without irony that um
indra justin and i all graduated from
yale school of management josh jabal
who's here with us who helped oversee
the state's response working with the
scientific community
yale school of management um we could
have had a couple more folks from
public health uh i think you were at the
right place
at the right time and really happy that
you're here
and hope that some of you stick around
um uh
so to follow the science of course i
needed dr albert co
and uh maritza to help lead the way and
so i'll just start as a governor um
you know what you know and you you know
what you don't know and
i came into this job as the first
business guy in um
you know decades and i come out of
telecommunications so
if you want to know what i was uh
thinking about in terms of um
you know outside of jobs the economy and
budget uh what was going to be the big
iceberg what we were really worried
about what could hit us
um probably given my background i was
really worried about a cyber attack
and uh you know we get pinged virtually
every day
hundreds of times and i saw um you know
municipalities and the such getting hit
up uh
you know for ransomware and the such and
uh so that's
that was the very first emergency test
that we ran through
our emergency operations center which is
uh right next to the state capitol
and um what was
helpful about it was i also had to reach
out to all my fellow
governors because we realized that a lot
of the threats
be it um rising tide cyber uh
germ um knew no borders so i got to know
um as part of that process governor
cuomo governor
baker new york massachusetts rhode
island and new jersey
and that served us pretty well as we
began hearing about
um uh covet the virus
and then things happen really quickly
um you know josh and i were you know
hearing a little bit about
wuhan and what was going on we went uh
to the um
i went to the governor's association
meeting then in washington d.c
that was probably in late january barely
mentioned
um what was happening there uh what we
did have was a secretary of defense
mike pompeo and he said whatever you do
have nothing to do
with the chinese because every time you
get a gift from the chinese
um uh it comes with strings attached and
i want to make sure
uh and i i reference that because you'll
see
uh what happened soon thereafter you
know from there
um from there we saw what was going on
at wuhan
and then seattle and then new rochelle
we were paying attention uh the virus
was getting closer
and then it was a saturday night in
early
march that we got the call
a nurse at danbury hospital was the
first
connecticut infection that we could
identify and
uh a shiver went up the spine and all of
a sudden it wasn't overseas it wasn't
over there
it was right here and
there all the training you've had in our
case
management your case public health
you got to reach out for the best and
the brightest
first thing we had to do was within a
week we called a state of emergency
that gave us a little more authority and
power to make decisions
quickly i couldn't have the legislature
in session because
it was um obviously risky having 187
people
under under that dome uh
you know within a week or so thereafter
we closed down high school basketball
and schools and then it really
came home what was going on
and it was in and around at that point
that um
we began thinking about look i i saw
what was happening in
queens not to mention um other places
where the hospitals were getting
overwhelmed
so first thing josh and i had to do when
it comes to reaching out the experts we
reached out to the hospital community
here uh in the state of connecticut
and to be a blunt um we had had the
state had a lousy relationship with the
hospitals in fact they were suing each
other for the last 10 years
fortunately we had put that behind us
and when we reached out we said we need
you
uh you maybe remember back then it was
flatten the curb make sure we don't have
that surge that could overwhelm our icus
overwhelm our hospitals like we saw in
italy like we saw in queens
and uh i'm we worked together really
closely with marner here at yale new
haven hartford hospital
um nuveen and and it made a difference
and all of a sudden our hospitals were
working together as one
and when stanford hospital was being
overwhelmed and greenwich hospital was
being overwhelmed
because the virus was marching like an
army from uh the greater new york metro
area
right up the uh metro north corridor and
the southern fairfield county and
danbury were the first to get hit
and at that point we had hartford health
and others you know bringing down the
troops bringing down what spare
mass we could find with spare vents we
were all
terrified about shortage events at that
time we've learned a lot
since then and nurses to make sure we
were never overwhelmed and
i can tell you that the water crested it
got pretty close
remember pretty close to the top of the
bathtub but it never
overflowed and at that point we're also
thinking about
um what more can we do
to flatten the curve and that took us to
looking at the folks flying in from
overseas
we had virtually no testing capacity at
that time you probably remember the cdc
said um
what few tests you do send them down to
atlanta and a week later
you may get a response and it was longer
than a week later
and then uh soon thereafter they said
you can use your own
estate lab and our lab could do maybe 20
tests a day
so let's say we are really um being
tight about you know
testing people who came in from wuhan
then as we expanded our
mix a little bit more broadly we were
able to start testing people with
symptoms or at least first responders
with symptoms
because we really had to make sure that
nurses could get back to the icus nurses
would keep showing up at the
nursing homes where we needed help food
service workers and others who were just
getting scared out of their minds
and that we could have had a total
shutdown and we had to do everything we
could to give people confidence
going forward and one of the things we
needed to give people confidence
was to bring in folks from business
and the healthcare community i did my
best to interpret what i was hearing
from um indra and albert but uh
that's what we needed and we had a david
shearer and a few folks
some spontaneous group of healthcare
professionals who are beginning to
think about what we had to do and we
brought them into the mix and we had
probably
um 20 leading health care professionals
everything from doctor co an
epidemiologist to folks who focused on
testing who folks focused on therapies
to start off and our job was to lead
with the science as
justin said and what i tried to do was
explain what we were doing in layman's
terms
i could not do this by fiat i could not
just order people wear the mask and stay
safe stay home or else i'm gonna arrest
you
i had to um do the best i could to
convince people that um
the very best minds we could lean on
we're strongly saying this is a life or
death
and if you're talking to a young person
who are maybe a little more casual
and invincible this is life or death for
your parent or your grandparent who
you're living with
and do the best we could um to convince
people this was the right thing to do
and uh connecticut um was very
responsive there early on
uh at the same time we had to do um in
terms of um
the mass uh we're all pretty socially
distant so
the dean said i could take my mask off
for just this brief
moment um there was no
supply down in washington dc you
probably heard don't worry the cavalry's
on the way it's going to come up from
you know the supply depot in washington
there's nothing there
and we went to our hospitals first of
all and they had maybe a two-week supply
of mass and gowns that at that point
were focused on vents
and uh at that point you had 50
governors
um scrambling doing the best we could to
find where we could get in particular
the mass
because it was a potential that our
economy and our society shut down if
people did not feel
safe and if we couldn't get the mass we
we couldn't stem the tide
and uh you know josh fortunately had um
had some work in the scientific
community so we're able to locally
uh source a lot of the um ppe
that we needed but uh uh that was not
enough and there was a scramble and
there was one state competing against
each other
and we'd have this stuff ordered and
it'd be landing at the airport and then
like uh
zoom pricing on uber the plane would
take off and go to a place where they
had had a higher um
offer for the same pp and uh at that
point
um i i think back to mike pompeo what he
said about
china in his dismissive way and we had
to fight we realized that um
connecticut and america don't have
control over their own supply chain
especially when it comes to uh um
at that point it was ppe later on we can
talk about antibiotics or we can talk
about other things where we need control
and um there we reached out to our
friends in the business community in the
political community and got some
relationships with china
and um you know chartered the plane the
plane was about to take off
china shuts down the border um finally
we got it to san francisco the trucks
got lost in their way here to
connecticut and finally um
finally at a nice day in late april
early may
we're all there with the nurses and
first responders cheering as the
tractor-trailer trucks
came in with the ppe that we needed
to survive uh at the same time
we wanted to think about what happens
next
and that's when um you know my dear
friend indranui had
been such a help to the state all along
the way she was helping with economic
development stepped up and said um
i think i know some people i think i can
help us get restarted and
um you may think gosh it was a little
funny time to be thinking about
restarting
um you know we were um you know
we had the fatalities on a daily basis
i'd be uh you know doing the tv press
conference every afternoon and everybody
was glued wondering what was happening
next as we
but we're also thinking about um what
does happen next and how we slowly get
back to a new normal
and first we had to think about how we
um close things down
and uh that was actually the peop the
folks at connecticut
were ready they knew what we had to do
by the time i closed down the schools
90 had already closed by the time i
closed down um
stores and hair salons and restaurants
um
people were already voting with their
feet and not wanting to show up
it was a little tougher with bars
actually guys
the bars were were packed st patrick's
day and then it was the very next day
that
we had to uh close those down but soon
thereafter
um you know with indra and the team of
uh
small business people that she put
together and folks from the association
we're also thinking about how you can
open
and open safely and you know there um
you know albert indra and i would have
some you know real debates cause
shut it down stay closed let's wait
until we're 100
safe let's wait until we have a vaccine
you know only then can you open but you
people were getting a little frisky and
it was spring and they'd been
locked up for an awful long time and um
so we had to give people a sense of
direction
uh that we were on the way um there was
a way out of here
and that's why on may 20th was the first
time that albert you know said look
they're bringing the infection right
down we flattened the curve
i think you can begin to do or you can
begin to slowly reopen
some things so we did some of the stores
in outdoor dining just to get a small
sense of normalcy back to what we were
trying to accomplish
and uh the good news is that i think uh
our reopen committee
we did it right and people believed that
they were doing it right
so they were voluntarily following all
the guidance and protocols that we had
put in place
and ever since that may 20th day when we
started reopening
our infection rate as a state has been
going down uh virtually
um every week thereafter and as uh you
know peter said we're
fortunately one of the very few states
that um have an infection rate in and
around
one percent uh that has been over the
last uh you know 90 days
uh you know that said um that's when
people start getting casual
and that's when we started worrying and
that's when i saw um
they reopened too soon in places like
texas and florida and
arizona and all of a sudden you saw a
hockey stick and it ramped up
so you had to balance the good news
going on in connecticut with the risks
that you saw elsewhere
and do as best we can to explain that to
people in a way that they could
understand so they would voluntarily
follow the protocols
so they would wear the mass even though
they didn't necessarily think they had
to
and there i got to tell you um
connecticut's been a leader i mean we're
more likely to wear the mass in just
about any state in the uh
country and um that's made an enormous
difference
and we put in place an advertising
campaign um
and just friends from omnicom helped us
with that and i was getting you know
do i have to wear the mask outdoors if
not within five feet of people what if
i'm in a screened-in porch
what happens if i'm inside or just with
my closest friends
and we came up with a motto if you have
to ask
where the mask and uh and that resonated
and made a difference uh i'm gonna
leave you with um you know one last
thought
which is uh you're all here at the
school of public health and this may be
uh
your opening week and um i didn't really
understand public health the way i
should have a year and a half ago when i
took office and i think i told you what
were the risks i was focusing on
given my background and thankfully um
there are a lot of folks smarter than me
in our state government
and uh we have deirdre gifford who came
out of hhs
and we had matt carter who's affiliated
here in our department of public
health working to catch up and then
state government can't do it all working
with the scientific community
working with albert coe working with
jackson labs working with uconn health
we were able to do this but i would urge
each and every one of you um
if you're thinking about what you want
to do along the way
we got internship programs for you
department of public health and a career
thereafter
because this is the beginning of
something not the end of something
and we need you more than ever thank you
governor lamont
that was a terrific review of where
we've been
many of us in the audience went with you
on this journey
i think our dean of our school of
medicine nancy brown who's
here in the front row had been on the
job
for four weeks
she started the first of february
ann kurth took responsibility dean of
our school of nursing
took responsibility for a lot of the ppe
crisis uh here on campus so
uh we we we took a role in in contact
tracing the school public health so
we've been
with you from the start of this and uh
we're very proud of our school of public
health students
who were quickly joined by school of
medicine school of nursing students
who served as a 200 person uh
volunteer group doing contact racing for
the city of new haven
so on that note uh you've already
answered the first question that's being
posed to you so i'm gonna
i'm gonna evolve that many of us thought
that your regional approach
where you and your fellow governors from
delaware
to massachusetts sort of
started to own that i-95 amtrak corridor
and tried to synergize your responses
could you comment just a little further
on that you mention it but i'd love to
hear
how that came about
uh two things i'd say one um
it was no help what was coming out of
washington d.c and the white house and
clorox and mass for wimps and a lot of
missed signals
and uh so we as fellow governors said we
have a pretty good bully pulp but we
wanted to speak with one voice in terms
of what you have to do from a
public health point of view and dean
also he realized
i realized there's a relatively small
state next to massachusetts and
new york that um i could close my bars
but that doesn't
make any difference if cuomo and baker
leave their bars open you got people
driving back and forth
that's even a lot more dangerous so we
tried to do when it came to closing down
was speak with one voice that allowed us
to better explain to people what we are
trying to do
and kept people closer to home excellent
and along with your chief of staff the
two representatives to that multi-state
task force were in fact
our reopened connecticut co-chairs uh
albert koh and indra noori who were with
us today
and i wanted to ask how did the reopen
connecticut advisory group
approach its mission there you were
given that you were given the
mandate by the governor how did you
organize yourselves and think about this
in the kind of strategic
response that uh that you uh embraced
and came out in your report
so when um the governor called me i
think on a saturday and said
i want you to co-chair this with albert
co i'd only seen albert on zoom i'd
never met him
really didn't know him so i came up on
sunday morning to the yale school of
medicine
and albert taught me the basics of
public health and epidemiology
it was like a multi-hour lecture because
you can't
really co-share something with an
epidemiologist and make decisions or
recommend decisions for the state
without understanding a little bit of
the science of the epidemiology
so it's very very important that first
meeting that albert and i had
and very soon we realized that the
shutdown was a suppression of the virus
and the longer you suppress the harder
it was going to be to come out of
suppression because had we stayed
suppressed for a year
economic activity would have struggled
massively and we wouldn't know how to
come out
of the shutdown so there was a critical
intermediate point where we had to dial
between public health
and economic health and when we decided
that we have to prioritize
economic health and sometimes and public
health and other times
we also had to make sure that anything
we opened
had the appropriate safety protocols so
the big discussion that albert and i
were leading with the team
we recruited the best and the brightest
scientists business people
it was amazing how many people
volunteered to be
on this reopen committee quit their jobs
temporarily to work on this committee
and i think we worked
um you know 18 hours a day for about six
to eight weeks
but everybody worked as a team and we
worked with josh and dave lehmann and
the governor
and what was amazing is they understood
the science
and it was a wonderful partnership where
we all worked together to decide
how best to dial these to public health
and economic
health of the state and get to the right
point where
you stay suppressed for a while and
slowly you start to open up
the right protocols so you don't have
another outbreak
that was a dance that was most difficult
to execute
so we went sector by sector put in
protocols
for opening and then for slowly ramping
up
and i think that's what served us in
good stead the fact that
we could recommend something with a
clear mind
objective and then the state took our
recommendations and modified it for the
state because
what we did did not really look at the
realities on the ground in the state
so the state then took it up and said
this is what we think makes sense this
doesn't make sense let's modify it so
it's a wonderful partnership between
the reopen connecticut advisory group
and the state
and albert what you want to add because
albert really was the
star of the whole reopen connecticut
because without albert's input
i don't think we could have had a
reopened connecticut task force
albert and i i really don't have much to
add i think that captured
the the the vision in the mission of the
reopening connecticut and of course this
was
this was um calibrated together with
you know people from the governor's
office the governor himself josh
you know josh javal david lehman i think
the couple things that
came out of this that was just to add
was that um
you know what made this different from
other states
was first of all it was done early i
think we were ahead of the curve in
terms of other states and
in what the governor said thinking about
how you're going to reopen you know
we were at the peak of the epidemic but
thinking proactively
the second thing was that it was
multi-disciplinary
um you know indra with her vision
brought in not only
the public health in the uh the business
and the economy but also the education
and the social you know the societal the
sports the education
the um uh the social services
all together until one one um part so it
was this
i think it got at this idea of
well-being rather than public health and
what
differentiated i think connecticut was
that we put well-being ahead
whereas other states just led with
either public health or they led with
one of the sectors like like business
and i think that's how we got
that that special formula and i think
that we're a tiny state as
as the governor said but when we first
started
we were looking at other states to see
how well they were doing they reopened
plans because
every state was setting up a reopened
committee but as we reached about the
five or six week mark
most states are calling us to say what's
connecticut doing because we like your
approach
so clearly the expert team will assemble
together was doing
a very good job and thinking through the
reopen and when the protocols were
published on how to reopen the state
some of the states that i was looking up
to like utah were calling and saying
can we borrow connecticut's protocols
you guys have the best protocols for
opening schools or colleges
or restaurants or whatever i said look
it's all on ct.gov you can have it all
it's really for humanity not necessarily
for connecticut
so i think that this partnership between
the reopened connecticut team and the
governor's office really worked well
you know i read the book the great
influenza by john barry
the last chapter of that book was
profound it really talked about
what needed to happen he talked about
a leader should be driven by science but
apply judgment
they should speak to the media honestly
without creating panic
they should make sure that they
understand the economic side and the
health side everything i read about in
that last chapter of the book
i think connecticut practiced if you
watched the governor's press conferences
they were honest fact-based
science-based
but they didn't create panic so
i think we were in many cases thanks to
you governor a bit of a textbook on how
we might want to approach
i hope we never have another pandemic
but we could write a playbook for
ourselves so thank you
excellent and what a great transition to
uh director maritza bond head of
our health department right here in our
city of new haven
you know that there have been
overwhelming challenges well documented
within the health sector
what dean brown and her counterpart dean
liang up at uconn faced with
marna bargstrom and her counterparts uh
leading
uh the health systems and hospitals and
clinics of the
the state um are are really
it was a it was a was a terrible story
at the same time
the health system rose to the occasion
managed to
get the ppe managed to care for the
patients managed to do their very best
to keep the death rates to a minimum but
what about the public health
system what challenges you faced
are not as well documented not as widely
appreciated
what were the greatest challenges in the
city of new haven
uh in your role as the new director of
the department of health and you just
walked in
as the mayor did and were hit by this
what were
some of your principal challenges in the
months of uh march and april
yeah so you know as you mentioned i was
the new appointed health director
uh my official first day was the 27th of
january
and i get a call from the mayor on the
26th
about a presumptive potential case of a
symptomatic individual that was visiting
from overseas and needed to be isolated
and then tested
so that was my first day so my first day
has been for the last seven months to
really
respond to to covid and
you know as a public health practitioner
not being new to public health but being
back in the city that even inspired me
to be in
um in this sector we have not seen this
form
of pandemic in over a hundred years
right so as public health practitioners
we know it in theory we want to prepare
and activate and the reality is that our
public health infrastructure has been
dismantled over the last few decades
that we needed to figure out an
infrastructure relatively
quickly and one of the things that you
know
the the mayor did as a collective is
that we wanted to activate a unified
command
approach um this needed to be a team
effort
with multi-sectors involved and
different lens
that included not just the government
partners but external partners
and realizing that that was going to be
the great
the best way to try to box in this
pandemic and so it really consisted of
you know i i love every point that was
shared earlier you know
the mayor shared earlier about
addressing inequities
and seeing how this pandemic early on
um started exacerbating the inequities
of specific subgroups and
how do we then create public health
interventions for those groups
how are we going to be transparent and
be forthcoming with the information and
early on not only was the governor
sharing
their weekly updates but we want to at
the local level be very specific
and transparent so the mayor was wanted
we did a daily presser
and we wanted to provide daily updates
to our local community on
what we're doing what our cases look
like in our city
and what interventions are in place and
available that was really important and
i loved the governor's comment about
there's no borders
and we were very conscious of that like
what's happening what are other cities
doing and so not only did the mayor
communicate with other local mayors we
were communicating with
other local health directors on sharing
resources because we really needed to
maximize
the existing resources and build an
infrastructure that was going to be
sustainable
well that's terrific to hear about the
regionalization
even at the city level you were thinking
about the region
and communicating uh with a central
command so that was terrific
so good opportunity to turn it over to
the mayor
you of course have been in the office
for a couple months
when this hit uh seems to be a recurring
theme here
and uh you've been credited for making
some very
firm and tough decisions early in the
pandemic response
communicating them very clearly and very
honestly
and uh i don't know how people in the
audience feel but i was very impressed
with your response
however in a leadership position like
yours
with the benefit of hindsight you're
bound to have
one or two or three things that you
might have done differently and we would
love to hear from you
sort of thinking about what what what
lessons learned
what might you have done even more
effectively in the month of say
uh february march uh to
to stem the disaster of april um
i would have hired director bond earlier
for starters uh she started working the
day before she started working which is
i
appreciate that and i and i have to
admit and i'm sure many people
have thought about if only we knew um
i think from time to time i should have
ordered 10 000 and 95 mass in january
right i'm sure our procurement
team would be like why are you doing
that but now that we know
um there's a lot of things that we would
have done
differently i do you remember when we
started wearing masks and we're talking
about how masks don't protect you they
protect other people
and now there's a lot of evidence that
says that they protect you as well
those are things that i think we all
experience together i i think
that um we will be uh
thinking for uh many years to come of
could we have saved lives by doing uh
certain things differently that
that we should have known to do
differently and
um and i know director bond and i have
talked a lot about this and
i think one area that um we might have
approached a little bit differently is
nursing homes
uh and and again it's hard in hindsight
to um or it's easy in hindsight to
say we would have done some things
differently but we lost a lot of people
in nursing homes
and uh you know i visit a number of the
nursing homes on a regular basis
and every time i go it it's very
emotional because
of you know
the residents holding signs for events
saying i'm a survivor
and you implicitly know that so many of
their
uh their
neighbors did not survive and uh
and and i think that there are things
that we could have uh potentially done
to help protect those individuals more
again it's in hindsight but i think that
you know these types of decisions will
weigh on many of us for
uh for a long time thank you
um you're absolutely right that was an
immense challenge and i believe this the
latest statistic is 60
63 of all the deaths in the state were
attributable to folks in
in nursing homes and assisted living
we're back to the governor uh you had
your break governor now we're putting on
the spot
connecticut hosts 169 discrete
municipalities
and assuming that this level of
decentralization is
challenging for effective pandemic
control
how have you and the state worked
efficiently
with this number of towns and cities
in lieu of what is a more traditional
kind of state structure working with a
larger county structure
well i'll tell you first off um new
haven was a star performer
new haven was a star performer in terms
of um
just the percentage of people that got
tested and how important that was and
and you may think yeah it's just a
matter of having more mobile vans and
more people get tested or making it free
or more people to get tested but
you really have to explain every day how
important i mean we would go
to um you know amy african-american
churches where folks are a little less
likely to want to get tested you get
tested you um
lose your job or you have to sit out for
two weeks what happens and
and um you know justin director bond did
just a heck of a job of convincing
people the importance what it means to
your family what it means to your
community
but you're right dean i mean we got 169
towns and uh it's the most incredibly
inefficient
structure and yet uh connecticut is
proud of its feisty independence
um you know we're trying to manage the
track and trace through
uh public health departments it's
working really well in new haven
you've been a leader there um it's
obviously a lot of the smaller towns
they need more guidance they need more
coaching and sometimes they need more um
you know expertise there to make it
happen we don't have a county form of
government so it it'd be easier to
manage on a top-down basis
but i think given the urgency that
people felt and josh's leadership
um even the track and trace which is
primarily being done on that local basis
to be done effectively
and when you have a one percent
infection rate it's a little easier to
track and trace everybody too
got it thanks uh let's turn it back
to uh our co-chairs indra and
albert um there is a question that came
in from the audience
that i thought i would throw in your
direction
um some models are suggesting
that there could very well be a surge of
cases
as early as november but possibly in the
traditional
viral respiratory season of december
through
through march and none of us know if
that's going to happen and
much of its behavioral mediated it may
be that people in connecticut are more
efficient at
controlling it won't happen but let's
just say
that we start to see a surge
this winter how might the response
differ from what our experience was
in march and april
okay so so i think a couple caveats to
that question uh
so as we're seeing in spain
italy france right now you don't need to
invoke a winter season
you know to have a significant uh surge
and so the the risk of a surge is is
with us
irrespective i think of a season now
we're particularly concerned about
what's going to happen in the winter
season
you know the the outdoor restaurants are
going to close
we're going to have people more spending
spending more time indoors
there's going to be higher contact rates
inside
closed uh closed encounters and then we
also have the specter of
influenza we already have you know
influenza
seasonal influenza peaks that take put
our health care systems into surge
crisis uh
quite quite often so so i think the
touch points or the pressure points
coming up into the winter season are
increased contact rates we're reopening
our schools
the second would be the cold cold
weather people having more
contact so what are what we're going to
do differently and
let me just say i think there are two
heroes in this story
the first heroes are i think the
governor's team the office the people in
department of public health many of
these people are are alumni
from the yale school of public health
i'm thinking about kristen soto who
stood up the contact tracing program
thinking about people like
matt carter who's uh who's a faculty
in our department of epidemiology
microbial diseases deidre gifford
who um you know i think one of the
unfortunate things we have
really you know thing we have um
things that really open our hearts what
you know the kind of the response is we
have also seen
things like last weekend where where our
commissioner of health
you know received threats because of
i think sound evidence-based decisions
about
you know stopping stopping football but
getting back
on track i think the you know those
those are
those are one set of heroes and they're
doing their job and i think they've
they've actually the governor's office
and i'd uh include josh
jabel and uh and michelle gilman who are
really implementing
you know sound policies they're getting
us ahead of the curve
and proactively whether it's
immunizations for influenza whether it's
getting up testing capacity
uh maximizing the opportunity to contain
so that's very different from
the situation we were you know back in
back in march
i think the second thing is that in
which i i i thought was remarkable and
probably the unsung heroes are the
citizens of uh
of connecticut you know they're wearing
the face masks
they're socially distancing we see these
metrics whether it's you know
you know through through different you
know contact phone contact rates between
cell phones
the citizens of of of connecticut really
have taken social distancing and all
their public health prevention to heart
and and i'm not sure we really
understand why that is and why
you know connecticut is different from
georgia or florida or even
even delaware pennsylvania but i think
we're
that is certainly different from when we
were
we were before you know at the in march
or february
you know at the at the start start of
the epidemic so
i think with sound policies
evidence-driven policies policies which
go beyond
what is you know expected you know from
the cdc or from the federal government
but i think that's been that's been what
we've seen in in connecticut
together with really the buy-in from the
population i think
we're going to you know the the
aspiration for us is through that
winter season to to be in containment
mode
you know uh rather than having to be
you know in a reactive mode to
resurgence
albert and i were teaching a class at
som last weekend
and a class with healthcare
professionals and
there was a student a practicing student
from san antonio texas
and he was the first guy to ask
questions and he said
we're struggling in san antonio we all
look to connecticut to see
how well you guys did the reopen that
was a big compliment
and so he said he's brought his wife and
daughter to show them connecticut
because
the state is doing so well i think
it's a good story overall excellent
thank you
i'm going to turn it back to uh director
bond
um you know in cut you mentioned that
the
infrastructure for public health
in the state has not kept up with need
and there was a there was an immediate
uh
demand both at the state level and at
the local health department level
to recreate structures that may have
been
in place 30 years ago but were not in
place the present time one of those
is contact tracing would you comment
on your partnership the partnerships in
april
that you used for immediate response
and what you with the state have done
uh now in september no absolutely so
one of you know as mentioned we had to
really talk about how we're going to box
in this
this pandemic so now that we had this
you know we were doing testing we were
isolating quarantining individuals
the way that works is utilizing a
contact tracing model
and we didn't have a system in place
when we
started the contact tracing so it was
more informal
in realizing we had public health
nursing nurses
or epidemiologists we knew that the
cases were greater than the staffing
structure that we had
and so we created a partnership with the
yale school of public health
where we then created a infrastructure
and expanded upon what we were doing and
it was
it was it was such a great success
because
it allowed us to be able to then engage
public health students medical students
nursing students
to then take theory that they're
learning in in their coursework
and then apply it to a live pandemic and
be able to support
um our our contact tracing efforts and
it was so instrumental
in being able to mitigate the pandemic
in our city
and you know fast forward um what did
that do we you know the state rolled out
a contact tracing
model across the state and so what we
wanted to do at the local level is be
complementary to what was being
rolled out at the state level because we
wanted to make sure that everything was
consistent and standardized
um that is the only way we are going to
be able to successfully
um do that and so we um then pretty much
transition into the state model where
we're now um having
a a couple of ways that we're addressing
it we're still using uh volunteers but
medical reserve corps
and staff still to roll it out across
the state so it's been really successful
um and you know initially
realizing that we needed to have this
infrastructure that was going to
um be able to address an immediate need
but then recognizing
the importance of standardization um to
it to be consistent with other
local health and state um health
department efforts
excellent thank you i'm going to get a
little parochial now with the mayor
how does the city view yale's reopening
because here yale university is
in the heart of downtown new haven
bringing students from i don't know how
many states
let's just say 45 states and 45
countries
uh all back you know in
in in the month of august early
september
how do you see yale and its
uh response and the way it's reopening
i i just wanted to first make a quick
comment on
the contact tracing because it was so
vital uh our partnership in particular
with the school of public health
uh to being quite successful at
identifying cases and ensuring there was
an additional spread
and it got a lot of attention and it's
it's funny uh
our communications person said all the
the bbc's reached out to uh
to talk to the city and i said oh that's
great i've never been interviewed by bbc
before and and our communication person
said no actually they want to talk to
director bond
and there was consistently things like
that because uh
the support in the relationship that we
had with the school of public health
uh in particular on that contract
tracing program
was something that was hugely helpful in
new haven but also was something that
my hope is because we got a lot of
attention and press on this that many
other communities were able to benefit
from that model as well
on your specific point about reopening
uh
we've been very um happy with the
approach that the university
has taken as to reopening
peter and i had conversations about the
importance of reopening because of
what you both talked about of well-being
and not just
using that keeping every person
healthy from covid perspective because
there's so many other
reasons that we need to keep our overall
society healthy
that lead to other health impacts if
people don't have jobs if they don't
have homes if they don't have a steady
income
there's all kinds of additional health
impacts and thinking about this pandemic
from
a wider angle about the economic impacts
and what they can do to the health of
our community
is something that i think is vital to
our success and the university
i think understood the importance of
opening up in a cautious
and very thoughtful way but they
understood the importance of it
and that's everything from the
quarantine period that you've instigated
the very very robust testing regime
the very serious
the students in the university taking
very very seriously
not having parties not congregating
we've seen what happens when that
doesn't
take place in other universities and how
that impacts not just the students but
the community at large
and so we've been very grateful that the
university has been willing to open
because new haven's economy is deeply
reliant
on the the university and people
physically being here
but doing it in a way that up till now
has
kept us very very safe and the cases
have been very very low
uh and and so i i just want to
underscore when you think about it
there's so many stories about the
universities we've been very happy with
how things have been going
hear that peter some good news for yale
for a change how's that
just kidding so
thank you mayor appreciate partnership
and
trying to do the right thing for campus
and for our
surrounding community appreciate your
support and partnership in all of this
absolutely well i can't believe that our
time is coming to a close
uh because i have more than a dozen uh
questions from the audience that we're
not going to get to so
i apologize to everybody who won't get
their question answered but i'm going to
end with the governor
and i'll end with a clustering of a few
of those questions
so one questioner asked where is the
federal coveted relief money for
local health departments and another
questioner asks
when will connecticut
really highlight the critical role of
local health departments
and provide more funding and more
consistent funding
commensured with their responsibilities
and another
a questioner asks
what will there this new national
dialogue
on the dangers of continuing to
underfund public health
in our country when how will that
translate at the state and local level
and they the questioner ends with a
commentary
local public health officials and
workers on the front lines
need our support protection and advocacy
so throw that to you sir
well we got our covent relief money and
uh
i think more than any other state
correct if i'm wrong josh we've
allocated a higher percentage of it to
test in anybody else
working closely with our local
departments of public health
you've been right on the front lines of
this and and if uh
as i suggested early on i have a
absolute new appreciation for how
important what each and every one of you
are going to be doing
in our local departments of public
health and
i just want you to remember one thing
because i have to remind
everybody all the time probably you less
so we're not out of the woods yet
and uh as you heard you know dr koh
say um you wanna know what i've been
worried about i mean i think k
through eight i think we can do that
that's a narrow cohort uh peter
i'm obviously a little more worried
about colleges like the dean said we're
coming from all over the region
higher infection areas yale and our
colleges have done it really well a guy
named rick levin maybe you heard of him
you know helped put together
our college committee and we've been
testing very thoughtfully on that
uh as people start going inside like dr
koh said i think november will be
a period of risk so my job is to make
sure that we keep our disciplines
something connecticut has
really led the country in and make sure
we realize that this is really
a very crucial you know 60 90 days
coming up and
um and and that's something
an urgency i have to repeat and uh but
more specifically your question i have a
new
fond appreciation of each and every one
of you
what you do how important you are going
forward i'm afraid this is not um
a 10-year or 100-year phenomenon it's
going to be more frequent than that we
got to be ready
and the public health and public safety
are side by side is our top priorities
thank you to you governor to you mayor
to our
uh heroes of the reopened connecticut uh
advisory group uh to our local hero
director bond thank you to all of you
appreciate deans
brown and kurth joining us josh chabal
from the state but most importantly our
school of public health students
this was an event that was
conceptualized by
albert and the governor on your behalf
to recognize you
and your uh future contributions to this
discipline thank you peter
and uh i bid you a good day
thank you everyone thank you everyone
all right uh harold would like a quick
photo
and i wonder if ann and